this is nakaria
even in this state the seasonal river is
a vital source of life
but its water is deep below the sun
hardened riverbed boreholes dug by hand
are the only way to get to it
a pecarica digs deeper and deeper it's
back breaking work
and it's dangerous the wells
there is a drought across much of
kenya's north
here in turkana the rains have failed
again
the water table is shrinking
these water wells are the only source of
fresh water for about a hundred thousand
people and the only reason they have
water in them today is because of a
flash flood
and this is kalakol town
it's entirely dependent on the water
holes
if there is no water and those wells
this that means there's no water for the
bottles and if there's no water for the
bottles there's no water for colorado
billy kepu is an environmental activist
he tells me the rainy seasons were
regular but now droughts are fiercer and
longer
driven by climate change
for quite a number of years
there hasn't been a lot of rain in this
area
so that has actually
been making life quite difficult besides
food crisis there is increasing also
need for water for the communities
around
are nomadic herders completely dependent
on their animals
they used to call their country the land
of plenty
but it's not anymore
the scrub
is burnt out there is no grass you can
see
bare and empty ground yeah
almost like those sheep are feeding on
the soil we've joined the world food
program as it reaches rural communities
hit hardest by the drought
alice moni is one of the young mothers
who is trying to raise a family with no
water and little to eat
the livestock starve so too do the
people
malnutrition is spiking
alice tells me her four-month-old baby
joshua is always hungry
the land is dry and hot she says there
is no water and her animals are diseased
or already dead
previous droughts in this region have
been catastrophic
and they can't let it happen again
we believe that climate change is a
driver of the many issues that we we
experience here we are increasingly
seeing
uh the the drought episodes and
escalating and increasing and therefore
households do not have enough of the
supplies of milk and meat
the children here know nothing of world
leaders meeting to discuss their fate
but they do know each day brings more
hunger and more thirst
and tragically
this is a crisis
not of their making
ashish joshi sky news turkana northern
kenya